cette audition s'inscrit évidemment
pleinement dans l'actualité puisque
votre groupe a récemment fait parler de
lui avec votre proposition de geler le
prix d'une baguette de pain à 29
centimes pendant quatre mois on en
reparlera envoyer les réactions
nombreuses et je dois dire que notre
invitation est antérieur à cette annonce
mais cet exemple regroupe hors groupe
plus élevé charge très bien informé sur
la stratégie de communication du groupe
cet exemple regroupe plusieurs des axes
qui sont au coeur aujourd'hui des
préoccupations des français et je n'en
doute pas de nos échanges de ce matin le
pouvoir d'achat et l'inflation la
rémunération bien sûr de l'amont
agricole qui est un sujet que nous
traitons souvent dans cette commission
ou encore les nouvelles habitudes de
consommation notamment alimentaires mais
avant d'aborder ces questions je
voudrais essayer de prendre un petit peu
de recul et je crois que c'est important
dans cette période dans cette période
voit la pré électorale pour vous
interroger sur les enjeux économiques
qui devraient être débattues dans les
semaines et dans les mois qui viennent
je rappelle rapidement que les centres
leclerc cesson 726 magasin simon
comptage est bon hier soir peut-être
qu'un at il plus ou moins ce matin 85 à
l'international 140000 collaborateurs en
france et surtout 18 millions et demi de
foyers français qui fréquentent chaque
année les centres edouard leclerc en
résumé je pense que vous êtes un acteur
économique centrale c'est à ce titre que
j'aimerais vous entendre sur les enjeux
des mois à venir trois thèmes la
souveraineté économique de notre pays
les conséquences économiques de la
colline et le pouvoir d'achat bien sûr
des français qui vont prendre tous ces
trois thèmes une importance pendant les
débats quel est votre regard michel
edouard leclerc sur ce concept de
souveraineté économique qui s'il est
facilement appréhendables pour nous tous
pour l'industrie les peut-être moins
spontanément pour le commerce en tant
que dirigeant d'entreprise quelles sont
les réformes économiques dont la france
aurait besoin notamment pour développer
les activités commerciales alors bien
sûr vous allez nous parler de réformes
fiscales et notamment de la réforme des
acteurs du numérique mais
identifiez-vous d'autres freins d'autres
obstacles à la pérennité d'un commerce
qui se transforme un commerçant dur et
se transforme sa tige et s'agissant de
la coville depuis le début de la crise
la grande distribution fait l'objet de
beaucoup d'attention dans un sens comme
dans un autre mais notamment pour louer
sa réactivité lors du premier confirmant
cette crise sanitaire puis économique
affecte tel toujours votre activité et
bien sûr si oui comment au niveau
mondial la crise a également des
conséquences qui est liée à
l'approvisionnement des produits à la
flambée des coûts du transport qu'en est
il pour les centres leclerc cela s'est
il traduit par une hausse des prix par
des ruptures de stocks on nous avait
annoncé une apocalypse des jouets en
décembre l'assemblée que le père noël
avait trouvé quand même les voies et
moyens de passer quel a été votre
politique en ce qui concerne les
pénalités logistique qui sont un thème
très chère à notre coeur ici est
particulièrement laurent duplomb face
aux industriels qui ont souffert de ces
tensions mondiales vous craignez une
inflation de 4 % elle est à cinq et demi
en allemagne à 6 aux états unis est ce
pour vous une inflation structurelles
conjoncturelle et surtout quelles
conséquences sur les salaires il ya des
initiatives de négociations par branches
qui sont aujourd'hui entamée parce que
le pouvoir d'achat c'est bien sûr le
prix auquel on achète les produits mais
c'est aussi la capacité à payer au
travers de ces rémunérations qui est
concerné en ce qui concerne les prix
alors que nous avons adopté et galim de
il ya quelques mois maintenant nous
souhaiterions
peut-être avoir un premier bilan partiel
bien évidemment puisque les négociations
vont continuer jusqu'au 28 février
de son application particulièrement chez
vous le maillot agricole pourra-t-il
espérer une meilleure rémunération à
l'issue de ces négociations
votre groupe c'est son adn met souvent
en avant la faiblesse des prix qu'ils
pratiquent et sa défense du pouvoir
d'achat des français comment
conseillez-vous cette demande répétée de
nos agriculteurs de pouvoir vivre de
leur travail car le risque de voir nos
agriculteurs abandonner leur activité
faute de rémunération décente est bien
réelle de même que celui d'une scission
de la société en deux entre ceux qui
peuvent manger français en acceptant
d'en payer le prix et se condamner à se
nourrir avec des produits importés qui
ne respectent pas toujours nos normes
très élevées comment appréhendez vous
ces risques enfin et je vais terminer un
peu plus à long terme nous savons que le
modèle de la grande surfaces de
périphérie souffre bien qu'il soit à mon
avis assez loin de l'épuisement total
quelles sont les actions entreprises
pour le réinventer comment suivre les
nouvelles tendances de consommation et
bien sûr quelle est votre vision si
l'irruption des plateformes numériques
gigantesque y compris dans le domaine
alimentaire
voilà monsieur le président tout les
sujets que nous souhaiterions vous voir
aborder ce matin je vous laisser la
parole pour un propos bien sûr liminaire
peut-être commencer à répondre là dessus
et je ne trouve pas que j'aurai plein
plein de questions et pas que sur la
baguette mais sur la baguette aussi
sûrement voilà monsieur le président on
et vous écoutez
madame la présidente et et vous tous je
vous présente d'abord alexandre tu à
lyon qu'est le directeur des affaires
publiques de des centres leclerc est
néanmoins mon ami on on fait route
ensemble depuis sept huit ans je les
piquets l'iris l'institut de recherche
stratégique
j'ai piqué à pascal boniface à un moment
où je voulais à mon âge reposer la
question de l'utilité sociale de la
marque lancer une troisième génération
de centres leclerc c'était bien d'avoir
des points de vue extérieur sociétaux
pour réécrire le manifeste des centres
leclerc en fait on n'a pas trouvé
il est assez fruste le manifeste initial
élaboré dans les années 50 etc mais il
fait sens encore aujourd'hui
puisque avant même la loi pacte est très
avant la loi pâques mon père avait été
influencé par des gens comme qu'on
n'enseigne plus mais capitan wallon
ce costaud qui ont alimenté les
gaullistes de gauche jusqu'à ce gars
jusqu'à et donc mon père avait dans son
contrat instauré trois volets un volet
pouvoir d'achat des chances du pouvoir
d'achat qu'on appelle après consumérisme
c'est l'expression était fruste dans un
contrat parce qu'il fallait être
opposable donc endroits les plus mettre
des choses concrètes que de que de la
littérature
associer les salariés aux fruits de
l'entreprise par la participation et
l'intéressement est aujourd'hui c'est
une règle majeure chez nous et qui nous
a permis de bien passé dans cette
période de crise et de manière homogène
si vous allez sur google vous verrez pas
beaucoup beaucoup de contentieux même
prud'homaux dans les centres leclerc ça
un peu outre une politique salariale qui
se tient bien on a
une un contrat qui amène tout centre
leclerc qui commence à faire des profits
on verse et 25% à ses salariés sous
forme d'intéressement de participation
il ya plusieurs régimes juridiques et
donc ça nous fait des beaucoup de
centres leclerc qui verse
deux mois trois mois quatre mois notre
convention de branche et déjà un
treizième mois mais dont on a des
équipes qui dure on n'a
plus de 87 % de cdi et en fait on a une
équipe homogène dont le prêt de 540
mille salariés dans l'enseigne dans
toutes ces entreprises qui sont
indépendantes parce que le troisième
volet c'est rester indépendant c'est de
permettre à des entreprises familiales
de de rivaliser non seulement avec leurs
concurrents mais dans le relevé le défi
les défis de la modernité je suis né il
ya soixante dix ans en 1952 quand mon
père construisait son premier magasin ma
mère à la pris des cours de comptabilité
les commerçants de l'époque n'avaient
pas accès à la comptabilité n'avaient
pas accès à la publicité
ils étaient tous indépendants et à
l'époque où jean claude jaunet
revitaliser
unico pour en faire système u à l'époque
où une femme comme madame catllar l'an
développeurs nouvelle 4le succursalisme
d'aidé groupe en entier déjà se sont
reposés la question dans l'économie
d'après guerre comment ne pas être un
goulot d'étranglement
alors qu on industrialise à la france on
allait vers le mass-market de ce qu'on
appellera les trente glorieuses et donc
dans ce parcours de presque 70 ans pour
visionner en tout cas d'accompagnement
professionnel on a connu beaucoup des
mutations et notre contrat à a tenu la
route alors cette crise elle est
intéressante parce que pour mon pour moi
avec mon vécu pour mes collègues centre
leclerc elle a surtout été un
accélérateur de mouvements plus qu'à
plus que créatrice de rupture le
discours ambiant parle beaucoup de
ruptures les jeunes aiment beaucoup de
parler de rupture bas c'est une manière
de tuer le père mais c'est c'est ça du
photo du freudisme primaire quand même
parce que en fait l'arrivée des
carrefours dans les années au milieu des
années soixante à sainte geneviève des
bois avec le one stop shopping venir
avec sa voiture faire des courses et
tous étaient dévastateurs et pour les
centres-villes et pour les commerçants
des rues principale et des rues
marchandes et même après l'arrivée des
hard discounters
d'origine principalement allemandes à
qu'il s'appelait déjà aldi lidl et
c'était avait complètement déstabilisé
les gammes de d'hypermarchés qui étaient
partis vers la montée de gamme et qui
avait un peu oublié toutes ses gammes
premier prix et autres et l'arrivée
d'amazon
aujourd'hui ou des amazones en pleine
période de crise a été quelque part
facilité d'une compréhension facilité
grâce à la crise parce qu'au fond tout
le monde s'est parlé s'est mis à parler
de click and collect pour des raisons
sanitaires on avait peur d'aller dans le
vente hyper et donc le sans aller
jusqu'à la livraison à domicile parce
que monter jusqu'à l'appartement en
crise sanitaire ça pose d'autres
problèmes on a vu toute cette politique
de plateformes cette politique de relais
qui a fait florès je sais pas combien il
en restera
dans dans quatre cinq ans mais vous
savez dans les enseignes de distribution
il n'en reste pas beaucoup non plus que
j'ai connue est un des fleurons des
rallidés des continents des mammouths
0 marché sait pas si vieux que ça voilà
donc je retrouve avec ce regard si vous
voulez bien
qu'ils regardent acteurs qui a connu
plusieurs crises plusieurs mutations
sont en accompagnement de ses parents
puis après
j'étais à la fac est journaliste et j'ai
encore vu ces choses là puis après je
suis rentré dans le mouvement et j'ai
vécu je les développer ce mouvement là
on est passé de l'ère du magasin de
landerneau un premier distributeur
français
c'est dans l'action je pense que en de
cette action on peut témoigner de la
manière de gérer une crise et comment on
en sort mais c'est aussi un formidable
l'observatoire des comportements sociaux
et
franchement vous êtes tous engagés
politiquement je sais pas on parle
d'élections primaires à 120000
d'élection de participation à 150 mille
deux cent mille personnes pour choisir
qui va sait on à 18 millions cinq cent
mille clients qui viennent dans les
centres leclerc et pas qu'eux qui
renseigne leur comportement et je vous
assure c'est un que quelques je puise là
avec mes collègues une source
d'information que je n'entends pas que
que j'ai l'air d'être un quelquefois un
gogo quand la restitue tellement il ya
un écart entre
ceux qui disent qu'ils sachent où qui
mesure et les comportements
et et cette crise finalement elle a
montré quoi elle a montré que pendant la
crise on a fait n'importe quoi on à
manger n'importe quoi d'abord on était
parti sur avec la loi et galim avec la
les états généraux de l'alimentation sur
quelque chose d'assez vertueux qui
pouvait tirer le renouvellement d'un
système de production de distribution
mais pendant la crise
on a dit tout que c'était le bio qui
avait marché non c'est pas vrai
c'est le snacking qui a qui l'a emporté
on avait dit que hay ans les enfants à
la maison tout le monde fait de la
cuisine pipeau 1 c c'est pas vrai on n'a
jamais vendu autant de pâtes au tandoori
autant de
deux plats transformer l'usiné
industriels etc des pizzas à gogo et des
plastiques et autant de plastique qui
ont été remis sur le vrac et c'est
maintenant ça s'est passé est quand même
la pédagogie de sa à réinstaller la
préoccupation sanitaire dans ou à
renforcer la préoccupation sanitaire
dans la consommation des français et
donc même si 1 1 un palier on parle
beaucoup de paliers là aujourd'hui si un
palier sur la consommation du bio par
faut dire aussi que c'est parti à 60%
plus cher que le naturel donc les gens
se posent des questions qu'un sur le
prix du bio mais c'est c'est
cette évolution vers un modèle
alimentaire plus vertueux pour
l'environnement moins impactant sur la
santé etc ça fait son chemin et je pense
que l'économie française
après avoir hésité dans mon ouest france
est là on fait de la résistance
granitique un peu là mais aujourd'hui je
pense que
même s'il ya des débats encore qui
traînent sur bien-être animal sur la
castration des ports sur le
la génération qui arrive là elle va
investir
va investir là dedans pour pour proposer
une autre offre et des boîtes comme elle
est comme elle décédée toutes les
grandes marques aujourd'hui au début
c'est des niches au début c'est du ces
du greenwashing et puis en fait quand ça
marche ça devient une vraie une vraie
stratégie et si c'est pas nous qui
allons ce sont nos enfants qui nous y
pousse donc ça c'est une première leçon
de cette crise la transformation du
modèle alimentaire français vers moins
de sucre moins de sel
plus vertueux et je vais pas développer
c'est en marche et
les résistances sont sont
si on marche pardon oui
qu'est-ce que je peux trouver pour les
républicains les socialistes dites moi
quelle est la phrase
je j'adore la littérature moi c'est
sûr le de l'autre sujet donc
alors peut-être alors l'autre toujours
sur la consommation l'autre sujet à
l'inter de ce sujet c'est
la prise de conscience d'une dépendance
économique sur ce qui sur ce qu'on mange
enfin le souverainisme c'est peut-être
l'expression une expression qui est pas
très populaire en fait
n'a quand bien même on la voit sur des
drapeaux mais cette idée du local de la
relocalisation cette idée du circuit
court cette idée alors elle était déjà
très forte on fait semblant de la
découvrir aujourd'hui mais même du temps
de mes parents et de jean pierre le roch
d'intermarché s'était déjà les amap
existait à face à veulent pas comme ça
mais
ça prend pas une grande part aujourd'hui
dans le système de distribution mais
c'est un
c'est quelque chose que les
distributeurs repropose de construire à
travers des filières ce qui sera pas
sans poser d'autres problèmes parce que
finalement ça vient - des producteurs
même que des distributeurs rappelez vous
que les filières de carrefour elle date
d'il ya 30 ans et à l'époque on leur
avait fait le procès de vouloir faire
main basse sur l'agriculture et donc
mais en même temps c'est ce qu'on nous
demande aujourd'hui on nous demande
de driver une meilleure production en
lui assurant des bouchers contrats à
long terme etc il aura un dossier dans
le dossier mais je sais quand même
quelque chose de très fort aujourd'hui
la relocalisation qu'on trouve sur les
problématiques de l'alimentation mais
qu'on trouve le masque je pose il vient
et que je porte il vient du groupe
lemoine
du côté de villedieu-les-poêles ou
quelque part par là
ils n'arrivent pas encore à faire le
prix chinois c'est
ces deux fois le prix chinois mais c'est
que deux fois le prix chinois donc c'est
sûr les autotests via une filière qui se
met en place sur beaucoup de choses
même dans l'industrie automobile di meo
renault cherche à faire une usine de
batteries en france on prend ça c'est un
deuxième sujet de la crise
deuxième effet positif de la crise cette
prise de conscience d'elle-même elle
nous a tous surpris la réaction de bruno
le maire l'expression de bruno le maire
dans le refus
lapidaire de laisser car bernard arnault
vendre ses parts de carrefour à couche
tard ça a surpris tout le monde mais
dans la réalité il a dit un truc
vrai quoi on est dans une période de de
reconquête de notre souveraineté la
distribution jusqu'ici était considéré
comme
un vecteur intermédiaires de cette
problématique en fait on s'aperçoit que
quand on a une distribution forte et qu'
elle joue le jeu elle est le driver de
cette relocalisation et donc nous en
avons pris aussi nous conscience à
travers des expressions comme ça c'est
une deuxième leçon de la crise nous
avons aujourd'hui près de 18000 leclerc
à près de 18000 contrat d'alliance local
avec des producteurs c'est beaucoup de
politiques c'est de la politique
partagée avec les élus locaux avec les
chambres de commerce locales etc mais
c'est le début d'une c'est une pédagogie
et c'est le début d'une reconstruction
de filières locales même dans le jouet
ça marche pas trop mal
la 3e
3e effets de la crise et l'accélération
du digital
franchement
moi j'ai été favorablement impressionné
de voir
les professionnels de mon milieu qui
parlait tout le temps du centre-ville ou
du petit commerce etc et bien tout le
monde est passé au minimum au clic et
collecte et tout le monde a pas
forcément fait mais tout le monde a à
personne et rentrer en résistance contre
la digitalisation on a connu d'autres
époques où sort était très l'époque de
sites d'une ati l'époque poujade
il ya eu une volonté de bien faire et
d'ailleurs des restaurateurs sont venus
sur nos plateformes les plateformes ont
proliféré presque ville par ville à
quand la blairiste orateurs étaient sur
le site soit de l'inter soit de deux
failles idée des libéraux peu importe
les marques qui se sont créés initiative
de prestataires de services avec
regroupement
d'indépendants qu'on n'aurait jamais
imaginé regrouper et donc ça c'est un
côté quand même très très positif
aujourd'hui parce que s'il est vrai
qu'on va discuter de rapports fiscaux de
discrimination sur la technologie
sur la technologie de la gestion des
entrepôts sur la technologie de la
gestion de la logistique la crise nous a
fait basculer petit ou gros dans dans la
remise en cause de nos systèmes les
pharmaciens quand on assez mis sur les
masques
n'avait pas de masque ok on avait
d'abord le système public qui savait pas
comment expliquer qu'ils avaient plus de
masques et donc c'est le discours public
était compliqué vous en avez beaucoup
parlé mais nous à partir du moment où on
a eu le feu vert pour aller chercher les
masques on a appliqué une logistique de
produits non alimentaires classiques et
on les a eu assez vite et par contre le
système pharmaceutique il était lié à
ces grossistes qui lui-même ou ses
répartiteurs qui eux même acheté aux
importateurs qui eux mêmes n'étaient pas
dans la réactivité et qu'ils étaient
dans des flux organisée donc on aurait
pu s'épargner beaucoup de querelles on
aurait pu acheter pour eux on aurait pu
mais ça nos pour le coup vous voyez dans
un groupe comme leclerc ou chez
intermarché système u pour le coup nono
logistique on l'a redécouvert étaient
des logistiques de crise quoi c est dans
la restauration dans la prestation de
services on voit éclore énormément de
services de service qui fait que ça se
développe très bien pendant le la crise
leclerc est devenu un des premiers
loueurs de voitures françaises
vous voyez demandé ça ya cinq ans je
n'aurais pas cru au loudes et zoé à 4
euros on loue des la petite spring dacia
l'a13 euros
à la journée c'est parce que
logistiquement c'est hyper construit
c'est sait des choses que je n'aurais
pas imaginé faire même dans une volonté
discount très développé donc ça c'est
important pour la crise
dernier point avant que de vous laisser
de bons échanges parce que je pense que
vous êtes un but et c'est ça qui est
intéressant c'est l'accélération du
c'est la vétusté de nos modèles
hiérarchique managériaux classique par
rapport à la nécessité d'être comme ils
disent en mode agile
entre télétravail entre délégations et
qui gestion déléguée à une cellule de
crise on a fait trois cellules de crise
les centres lyon fait trois cellules de
crise différente pendant cette crise
on a appris à redevenir agile moi j'en
fais pas parti je ne me suis pas mis du
tout dans dans la chaîne exécutive pour
ne pas parler les décisions d'une pseudo
vertus de la marque etc fallait que tout
çà çà çà et sur objets sur objectifs et
vous avez vu les autotests comment léo
on les a eus rapidement et en baissant
les prix d'ailleurs
nous ne savons toujours pas si dans
quelques jours il va falloir arrêter de
les vendre et c'est pourtant le moment
où on est en train de faire baisser les
prix et voyez c'est ça fait partie on en
a discuté donc ça c'est une leçon de la
crise aussi entre
avoir des salariés 3 à 4 jours en
télétravail dans les sièges ou dans les
services administratifs
des avantages ça des à cause des
problèmes de s'imposer contre les
familles c'est à cause des problèmes au
travail ça cause des preuves de
visibilité
c'est un enseignement de la crise et
voilà donc dans cette période leclerc a
surperformé je voudrais dire avec fierté
que autant j'appréhendais j'étais hyper
angoissé en début de crise autant j'ai
vu d'abord les tout le monde revenir sur
le terrain
ramasser les mouchoirs parterre remâché
les masses par terre j'en a vu
l'application des mesures sanitaires
à change enfin à donner des valeurs
fortes à ceux qui
étaient sur place devaient protéger
devait rassurer ils ont une part de voix
qui est redevenu forte le terrain a pris
beaucoup de poids par rapport au siège
et puis la réactivité commerciale
où l on a on a fait plus de 3 5% de
croissance l'année dernière
on est sur un trend de croissance
identique malgré des magasins redit
coupé avec des secteurs essentiels d'un
essentiel dé toutes ces histoires là on
n'a pas eu de klosters et je devrais
dire ça en premier on n'a pas eu de
kloster
et
donc de cette crise je pense que de
l'observatoire d'où je suis je pense que
il faut retenir tous ces expériences
positives qui devrait nous permettre là
maintenant de gagner la bataille de la
sortie de crise parce que je vous le
confirme on est dans une croissance
soutenue la consommation tirent la
croissance parce qu'on a quelques
problèmes à l'export mais
la croissance tient son rang et la lame
menaces qui pèsent sur cette croissance
c'est le retour à l'inflation
l'emploi on a quand même des bons
indicateurs qui sortent les faillites y
en a pas eu tant que ça on sait le prix
du quoi qu'il en coûte on sait mais ça a
marché enfin ça nous nous sommes
associés leclerc avec les italiens du
groupe coop italia donc on connaît assez
bien ce qui se passe en italie on est
associé avec le groupe rêver allemagne
ils sont présents dans 13 pays européens
allant jusqu'à la russie et on est
associés à l'achat mais aussi en
développement de systèmes nouveau avec
le groupe delhaize à hold de lèse qui
est 40% pays bas belgique mais aussi
états unis on a cet observatoire on peut
vous dire que la la
dans la gestion de cette crise au delà
de tout ce qu'on a critiqué ce pour quoi
on a râlé
j'ose dire je suis pas en campagne
électorale je me présente pas j'ose dire
que l'état
bercy m'a impressionné par sa souplesse
par sa présence et ça a été toute notre
filière agroalimentaire a été très bien
drivé alors évidemment ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire aussi un retour de l'état
très fort quelquefois de manière
autoritaire alors quelques fois c'est
pour sanctionner quelques mais d'une
manière générale l'état était à l'ecoute
de petits et grandes entreprises et je
trouve qu'on sort avec un modèle
français qui est pas si mal que ça de
d'un état qui revient mais en même temps
d'un dialogue qui fonctionne pas mal
j'ai fait trop lent non non non vous
avez pas fait assez ac non d'ailleurs
parce que j'aurais bien aimé vous
entendre sur inflation structurels ou
conjoncturels
voilà mais je suis sûr qu'il y aura des
questions là-dessus et j'apporterai
juste un petit bémol à ce que vous venez
de dire sur les
la féliciter gouvernement qui est hier
on a quand même appris qu'on avait le
record absolu de faillite en ce début
d'année donc il ya quand même un petit
sujet dans la pérennité voilà maintenant
qu'on a passé la période où on a bien
aidé les entreprises et on a dance est
dans cette assemblée
accompagner ce mouvement on a évidemment
des inquiétudes un peu pour la pour la
suite alors il ya de très très
nombreuses questions dont je vais vous
demander à tous d'être le plus con si
possible parce que sinon donc je revois
on peut faire une question une réponse
moi je sais pas vraiment retenir trois
questions
je suis un peu étonné alors je vous
propose un compromis à 3 pour mon voyage
ont fait on fait enfin devant vous avez
une force forte agilité je vous propose
trois questions et ensuite un show le
plus détesté ça ben ouais parce que du
coup on répond que ce n'est pas spontané
alors on va faire comme vous voulez
michel edouard leclerc mais alors je
vous donnerai deux minutes pour
rejoindre voilà la grolle d'un couple la
contrepartie à à la spontanéité on va
commencer par monsieur le président de
la délégation aux entreprises auteur
d'un rapport sur l'évolution du commerce
acheva baril
il est là bas merci madame la présidente
monsieur leterme ciboure lourd
je vais pas
spécifiquement
parler et vous interroger sur
l'évolution du commerce
la révolution du commerce vous en avez
dit un mot et c'est pas tellement le
sujet ce matin le sujet c'est la sortie
de crise qu vide et dans les points
qu'ils ont été
annoncé par le président sur l'inflation
les conséquences du colis elle apparut
le terme de souveraineté économique qui
vous l'avez repris d'ailleurs et je
voulais plutôt
vous interroger sur ce sujet là parce
que évidemment nous pensons
à notre niveau aux pme dans nos
territoires et à leur sort en terme de
deux possibilités de développement au
regard de la
de la désindustrialisation de notre
territoire ça apparaisse dans les
chiffres du déficit commercial on est à
70 milliards sur 2021 c'est considérable
et
les éléments qui peuvent être mis en
avant vous les avez cité d'ailleurs et
on voit apparaître le rôle de la grande
distribution un rôle positif dans ce
sens cet élément là j'aimerais bien que
vous puissiez nous les préciser la
relocalisation les circuits courts les
filières sont nés trois points vous avez
mis en avant bien entendu
je pense qu'il faudrait que vous nous
préciser le rôle que vous pouvez jouer
là dedans on est marqué par un certain
nombre d'incidents par exemple les
entreprises à qui on a demandé de
fabriquer des masques les appels
d'offres publics continuent achetés les
masques chinois à cause de la différence
de coût que vous avez évoquées donc on a
des gens qui ont investi qui on est et
flexible très réactif et qui finalement
ne tire pas profit de de l'heure de leur
activité bon c'est sur ce plan là que je
vous montrais avoir des précisions de
pas un rôle de deux groupes le club
remercie alors le
la conscience l'urgence et l'obligation
de faire est inscrite dans le cahier des
charges de notre groupement est donc
notre comité stratégique qui regroupe
les 16 présidents de région français
plus les quatre présidents de deux pays
dans lequel on est implanté parce qu'ils
ont le même problème au portugal ils ont
le même problème en espagne
on a donné dans les lettres de mission
de chaque groupe de marché
de trouver tout le temps un pourcentage
minimum de produits français sur les
segments à construire et donc on avance
de manière très prosaïque très
pragmatique masque
jouer
et donc la sélection
à noël on avait pas mal de marques
françaises on sait pas trop occupés du
prix je vous dire et est en fait au fur
et à mesure on prend contact avec chaque
filière on regarde qu'est ce qui a comme
offre française et je pense qu'il ya des
synergies il ya des alliances objectifs
comme aurait dit feu monsieur marchait à
une émeute à une époque pour
construire reconstruire des filières
françaises mais monsieur si vous êtes
d'accord c'est bien un travail à 15 ans
ce n'est pas un travail à
c'est pas maintenant ensuite il faut je
pense faire attention le fait
émotionnellement ou politiquement on
associe toujours les pme à la reconquête
du marché intérieur et nous on a fait
pareil avec des alliances locales mais
dans la réalité rationnelle c'est le
mass market qui pose problème c'est mass
market qui fait que c'est des
entreprises de grande taille qui vont
chercher en chine qui sont organisés et
c est donc
la
ccc des séries plus longue et cette
crise je pense fait prendre conscience
pas mal
anne sur nos amis par exemple du
choletais qui avait tout délocaliser
leurs textile à une époque j'ai trop
fait prendre conscience aux vosgiens et
et aux jurassiens qu'il fallait garder
un tissu industriel la plasturgie et
tout ça alors ils ont à gérer aussi la
loi climatique mais c'est je pense qu'on
est
je pense qu'on est dans le la réponse
est on sait prégnant le breton que je
suis veut qu'on re régionalisant très
bien merci alors je fais le gendarme
je ferai le gendarme aussi avec laurent
duplomb qui comme les autres à deux
minutes
[Rires]
merci merci madame la présidente je vais
essayer d'optimiser ses deux minutes
monsieur michel edouard leclerc j'aurais
pu dire de vous vous êtes un très bon
communicant e vous savez actionner les
coudes comme comme personne et en
particulier la baguette à 29 centimes
que vous vous présentez comme le
chevalier blanc du consommateur tout en
faisant savamment oublier que vous
enrichissez puisque dernièrement et
c'était un article qui vient de paraître
vous êtes enrichi sur 2021 le prêt de 75
millions d'euros augmentant votre
rémunération de plus de 40 millions
d'euros par rapport à 2020 je reprends
juste
il n'en reste il n'en reste pas moins
vrai il n'en reste pas moins vrai
monsieur leclerc que vous avez quand
même une capacité particulière à
contourner les lois vous le faites à
travers votre centrale européenne
leclerc qui refuse de se référer au
droit français et continue de demander
de la déflation sur les matières
agricoles même si parfois vous accepté
de le faire donc cette prise en compte
de la loi et galim concernant les
matières à l'école vous faites
exactement ce qu'il faut pour compenser
toute augmentation que vous payez par
une diminution que vous appliquez sur
les différents produits de consommation
courante non alimentaires vous appris
vous appliquez un véritable jeu de dupes
sur les pénalités puisque ces pénalités
aujourd'hui sont encadrées par la loi et
galim 2 il semblerait comme en bon
communiquant je vous ayez été le
meilleur pendant la crise c'est à dire
celui qui demande le moins de pénalités
mais comme le naturel comme chassez le
naturel il revient au galop vous vous
êtes extrêmement bien appliqué à
appliquer la totalité des pénalités
après la crise
de façon à regagner tout ce que vous
aviez perdu au départ
continué de plus belle en modifiant en
modifiant les pénalités par interne
nouveau qui s'appelle pour vous
indemnités logistique vous continuer de
pratiquer des déductions d'office sur
les factures de façon totalement
arbitraire la question vous pénalisez
vous appliquez vous appliquer des
pénalités sur les commandes non il faut
l'entendre ça vous appliquer des
pénalités sur les commandes portant sur
des produits annoncés en rupture par vos
fournisseurs alors monsieur leclerc ma
question est simple chaque
le respect de la loi et il dans votre
cahier des charges
alors
j'apprécie votre accueil et est donc on
va garder
malgré la crise je vous propose de
regarder un ton bon enfant pour que
chacun sorte la tête haute parce que
sinon il ya 6 et vu ça on va dire que
vous avez pas trop faire importe
travailler vos collaborateurs et vos
rapporteurs sur sur ce que vous dites
parce que je ne suis pas le michel
leclerc dont vous parlez
le michel leclerc qui est dans le top 10
des fortunes de france ss et michel
leclerc avec un q moi j'en ai qu'un et
il est le fondateur de décathlon et et
je ne suis pas ce michel leclerc là
d'accord et moi je ne suis plus salariés
des centres leclerc depuis cinq ans au
patrimoine je peux vous dire est à peu
près l'équivalent d'un d'un petit
hypermarchés et est donc et je peux bien
mes impôts en france et donc je ne suis
pas ce
leclerc que tout le monde sort la ddt
sur les réseaux sociaux et quand bien
même enfin on est bien d'accord mais
mais non ce n'est pas moi voilà
donc il faut faire travailler autour de
nous pour
deuxième chose non nous n'avons pas
donc deuxième chose c'est vrai que c'est
ce que
20 ne vont pas aborder ces négociations
commerciales en déflation nous sommes en
inflation j'arrête pas de le dire et
d'ailleurs je suis le premier à le dire
j'ai démarré peut-être un petit peu trop
tôt personne ne me croyait mais nous
sommes sur une inflation quasiment de
même type qu'en allemagne en allemagne
les écarts sont plus grand parce qu'il
ya eu un changement de taux de tva
mais surtout le gouvernement français a
réussi à enlever de l' indice des prix
l'impact de la hausse du prix de
l'énergie de l'électricité et du gaz en
les bloquant en plus l'insee les lis
les pondère n'ai pas d'idée bidouille il
les présente différemment qu'en
allemagne je vous dis qu'on est sur un
trend d'inflation de 4% ce qui est
l'équivalent du 5,7 pour cent allemand
ce qui est par l'équivalent du 6,1 aux
états unis mais on y est donc nous ne
sommes pas idiots nos propres factures
d'électricité augmente je sais pas
l'impact des dernières lois de monsieur
le fin des dernières propositions de
monsieur le maire mais nous nous on a
une facture d'électricité dans les
centres leclerc qui augmente de 200
millions 250 millions donc on est nous
aussi on est en installation tout le
monde va être en inflation il ya des
factures qui seront difficiles à
renégocier si toutes les factures amont
notamment de transport parce que aucun
de nos grands opérateurs ne pèse
beaucoup par rapport aux grandes
compagnies internationales qui ont les
conteneurs et tout ça donc ça c'est de
on va sans encaisser ces hausses il ya
les hausses de l'énergie industrielle
agriculture qui a les hausses de
matières premières et donc je vous dis
on va vers une inflation de 4 % que ne
pourront pas absorber nos 18 millions de
consommateurs de leclerc donc nous
allons sculpté tout ça en dit avec
discernement avec les industriels s'agit
pas de dire que ça n'existe pas mais on
peut pas faire un mur d'augmentation de
prix là le fin mars juste après le salon
de l'agriculture au hasard on peut pas
faire ça et quand bien s'appeler ray à
la fnsea quand bien même ça plairait au
lobby des industriels de l'ilec sait
jamais qui vont l'assumé c'est dans nos
magasins que ça va se passer donc on va
essayer d'être intelligent on va essayer
avec les grandes entreprises de le
diluer on va d'abord demandé de la
transparence
sur les marchés de matières premières
c'est pas des industriels ont fait
monter les prix s'est défoncé les fonds
qui investissent et des fonds qu'ils
jouent cdc des fonds joker y compris des
fonds d'état y compris des fonds chinois
donc
ça montre le blé redescendre 1 2 donc
voilà je réponds à votre question dont
nous ne l'abordons pas la négociation en
déflation non je ne suis pas ce michel
et leclerc là ça va bien pour moi mais
j'ai pas je suis pas au 10e étage de
l'ipad est pas lui non plus c'est un
nordique alors forcément évier en
connaissance de contentieux de pénalité
la loi et galim on commence à rentrer
dans les discussions
les pénalités elles ont été codifiées
ans et epc
interprofessionnelle mans et ça a été
repris par la loi et galim je suis
désolé le législateur a accepté au
considéré qu' il fallait y avoir des
sanctions dissuasives pour éviter des
ruptures de chaîne logistique comme on
l'a connu et on a fait jouer ça pour
avoir nos jouets mais il n'y a pas de
contentieux il n'y a pas de mauvaise foi
et pour le moment la négociation
commerciale faut pas dramatiser c'est
compliqué la loi il y allume être très
compliqué c'est service juridique de
chaque boîte qui va discuter mais s'est
on part pas dans l'agressivité
j'étais trop longtemps c'est pas grave
je crois que c'est important daniel
grémillet ensuite sylviane noël
oui merci mesdames présente sur le
président
jouait pour longer la question de
laurent duplomb
je préside le groupe de suivi avec mes
collègues du sénat
l'application de la loi et galim
ce président au partage que vous venez
de dire mais la réalité c'est ce qu'a
dit notre présidente le bouleversement
entre la fin 2021 elle début 2022 on
rentre on rentre jouer dans la réalité
économique
vous avez cité votre propre exemple
d'orientation des énergies pour le
groupe leclerc
de ce que l'on sait et je peux vous
assurer qu'on sera très attentif sur la
fin des négociations mais les
négociations sont plutôt complexe et
aujourd'hui non mais mais ouvrez la tête
il faut qu'on soit
cohérent avec le discours
vous parler local vous parlez de vos 18
millions de clients du groupe leclerc
mais leur intérêt aussi c'est que
l'économie de notre pays sont en
cohérence aussi sinon ça ça marche pas
si ça consiste à g a écroulé
effectivement notre économie ça marche
pas donc ils joueraient vous entendre
sur effectivement ces hausses tarifaires
qui sont nécessaires rien là par un gros
pressing non négociable la matière à
l'école mais les entreprises sont comme
vous confrontés à des éléments
extérieurs qu'elle ne maîtrise
absolument pas
et c'est pour ça que je dis on rentre
dans la réalité la bulle est en train un
peu d'exploser la réalité économique
ouais et de la capacité du pouvoir
d'achat aussi de nos consommateurs qui
foré sur lesquels il faut être attentif
donc ma question est simple où en êtes
vous dans cette acceptation ou pas de
l'augmentation tarifaire de
l'incompressible et de la vie économique
des entreprises
deuxième question qui met en découlent
c'est comment imaginez-vous qu'on va
pouvoir garder en france à capacité de
produire y compris pour les 30 % de
français qui ont un pouvoir d'achat très
faibles donc il s'agit pas non plus
d'externalisation
alors je crois que madame présidente
dernière remarque monsieur le président
vous avez inventé la réussite du groupe
leclerc sur la voiture zoé à 4 euros par
jour moi je voudrais vous l'interrogez
pourquoi et comment les chèques de l'eau
claire sur la distribution des richesses
est et enfin puisque vous avez parlé des
volvo d assurer que vous si vous voulez
vendre locale il ya encore beaucoup de
masques de disponibles dans les
entreprises textiles des vosges merci
daniel lauzon très con si je vais
essayer ce un bon exercice pour moi de
mai c'est de répondre et posé beaucoup
de questions pertinentes mais
leclaire a été le premier c'est un
signal que je voulais que la fnsea
entendent que julien normandie entendent
nous avons été les premiers à appliquer
les hausses tarifaires sur les pattes on
l'a fait discrètement c'était 20% sur
les parts nationale des marques
nationales et 30% sur les marques de
distributeurs je vous assure que le camp
si vous vous avez des amis qui sont
commerçants vous commencé comme ça
le mois de octobre
vous regardez quelle réaction d'accord
d'abord première chose on s'est fait
épingler par le parisien on s'est fait
pas elle donc tout le monde nous dit il
faut augmenter les agriculteurs on
soutient et tout ça on applique la
hausse tarifaire qui elle sortait de
égalise ainsi on n'était pas dans les
galim 2 on s'est fait ramasser d'accord
et le prix des pâtes le marché des pâtes
aujourd'hui parce que les concurrents
ont fait la même chose mais après nous
le marché des pâtes c'est moins 20% irie
o'neal scène c'est moins 20% donc cette
réactivité on a des on a tous sont venus
ce document de 1000 salles
jusqu'où l'inflation pourrait elle aller
etc à l'impact je vous assure que autant
petit 1 oui nous allons faire passer les
inflations nécessaire petit 2 on a quand
même les pétoches de ce qui va arriver
et on devrait ensemble se poser la
question de savoir jusqu'où et comment
il faut le faire faut pas casser la
croissance je crois que on pose les
bonnes questions 1 d'accord voilà alors
dans je vous donnais un deux autres
chiffres qui mériteraient d'être affinés
aujourd'hui on l'a reçu à peu près
toutes les demandes de hausses
tarifaires
enfin les les centres leclerc dans leur
centrale dans les différentes centrales
d'achat et puis à des systèmes on achète
local on l'achète nationale si on fait
l'analyse
cumulait on a 25 % de notre chiffre
d'affaires qui est impactée par une
hausse moyenne de 6% sur l'alimentaire
et de et on a un autre 25 % de chiffre
d'affaires impacté par les hausses dues
aux produits non alimentaires et ses 7 %
ces deux demandes
ce sont des demandes sur la partie
alimentaire application des galim 2
on va première chose demandé de la
transparence mais il faut que vous
sachiez que les fournisseurs ou ça vous
rappelez ils ont trois scénarios à
proposer pour justifier de
l'augmentation des produits agricoles
ils ont pratiquement pas choisi celui de
la transparence
soixante pour cent des lits pour 120 90
% pions 3,4 et 90% hop 103 on doit se
prendre les os et éventuellement aller
chercher à un tiers de confiance après
pendant je sais pas combien de temps ça
va ça va bien faire travailler l'emploi
chez les consultants ça et donc c'est
pour vous dire que ça fait quand même un
mur de hausse de prix donc j'insiste
auprès du monde agricole des des
sénateurs qui sont très liés au monde
agricole nous allons appliquer ces
hausses
avec discernement
en faisant attention
on va en discuter avec eux de toute
façon parce que monde
quand on est dans des contrats
pluriannuels on peut peut-être mais il
n'avait pas l'habitude de ça on peut
aussi peut-être lycée ces hausses
les prêts qu'on pensait d'un
retournement du marché du blé par
exemple au printemps prochain enfin vous
voyez il ya je suis pas technicien de la
négo il ya plusieurs manières de faire
moi mon souhait c'est de ne pas opposer
aux consommateurs un mur de hausse et
c'est ce qui fait que d'abord parce
qu'on va me l'attribuer on va attribuer
à nos centres leclerc à nos intermarché
à nos système u on va les attribuer on
va pas les attribuer à aux industriels
veut pas les attribuer à fleury michon
il n'y a pas un industriel qui va aller
à télévision pour dire c'est moi qui
fait augmenter les prix chez leclerc
donc à partir du nom j'ai cette
responsabilité auprès de nos 18 millions
de clients
on va faire ça mais en même temps là où
je suis pas d'accord c'est quand on
vient m'obliger à dire à la télévision
que je vais augmenter des prix ce qui
fait que moi je vais augmenter les prix
c'est que je vais
compenser je vais compenser sur neymar
je vais compenser par des actions je
vais choisir des marqueurs de la
consommation pour ne pas effrayer ou
pour compenser et c'est pour ça qu'on
vend de l'essence à prix coûtant et
c'est pour ça qu'on a mis les masques à
prix coûtant c'est pour ça qu'on a mis
les autotests en avant c'est pour ça
qu'on a mis la baguette on n'a pas
baissé le prix du pain on la gelée
pendant six mois il était déjà à ce prix
là mais pour il faut nous laisser gérer
le rapport de confiance avec nos 18
millions de consommateurs pendant que on
transfère cette valeur ajoutée en amont
à commerce vous rappelez pas vous êtes
tous trop jeune pour vous rappeler de
fernand raynaud mais vous on peut pas se
mettre devant
on peut pas se mettre devant un magasin
en disant venez chez moi à acheter mais
orange elles sont plus chaleur
très bien merci michel edard je subis
jaoui coupé parce que le but du jeu
c'est de vous répondez vite donc vous
répondre et lui tout à l'heure que
j'accepte autorités
comment
réaliser sur les sites et je suis cool
avec les dames 1 un bonus à l'elysée sur
l'électricité l'électricité on a été les
premiers à dire que c'était absolument
dingue de nous lancer dans un marché qui
n'était pas déconnecté même
marginalement du prix du gaz et donc on
est parti sur des abonnements
avec des abonnements alternatif soutenu
par la commission de l'énergie la
commission européenne ça a très bien
marché on a eu 140 mille abonnés quand
nous nous sommes aperçus que les thèses
françaises de déconnexion du prix de
l'électricité du prix du gas des
énergies fossiles et ça ne marcherait
pas on a arrêté nos abonnements
contrairement à ce qu'on dit on n'a
laissé personne en rade on a démarré
très très tôt mais discrètement il ya eu
personne de léser dans nos contrats
personne personne tout le monde se
foutait de nous mais maintenant ils y
sont tous voilà et nous on n'a pas coûté
à l'état
très bien sylviane noël
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
président je souhaite vous interroger
rapidement sur trois questions dont une
partie a déjà été abordé par mon
collègue pas de redondance pas souvent
du plomb bras très vite sur le prix de
la baguette à 29 centimes pensez vous
sincèrement qu'ils soient responsables
et pertinents à l'époque on cherche à
revalorisation juste prix la
rémunération des agriculteurs et
peut-être à rappeler à tous citoyens que
derrière un produit quel qu'il soit il y
à des agriculteurs et des ouvriers qui
doivent être rémunérés pouvoir vivre
dignement
pensez vous qu'ils soient vraiment
responsables d'affiché de tels prix
aussi bas et puis s'agissant des
pénalités logistique apparaît apparentés
à des marges arrière vous y avez répondu
dont je n'y reviendrai pas j'aurais
juste une dernière question j'ai été
particulièrement surprise de l'évolution
de votre opinion regard des contraintes
sanitaires des protocoles sanitaires
imposées à vos magasins puisque le 27
août vous réclamiez la fin du pass
sanitaires dans les grands centres
commerciaux depuis de vingt mille mètres
carrés alors que le 5 février 5 janvier
dernier pardon vous déclariez sur ces
news ne pas voir d'un mauvais oeil je
vous cite la mise en oeuvre éventuelle
d'un pass vaccinale à l'entrée de vos
magasins montrant même un certain mépris
à l'égard des personnes non vaccinées
que vous laisseriez 1 c'est à la porte
ce qui n'a pas manqué de faire réagir
bon nombre de consommateurs qui ont
appelé au boycott de au magasin vous
pouvez vous nous apporter quelques
éclaircissements sur ces variations pour
le moins surprenante sur l'objet même de
commencer par ça j'ai absolument pas de
variation il vous vous avez raison c'est
nous qui avons
l'année dernière
fait des requêtes auprès des tribunaux
pour ne pas avoir appliqué le pass
sanitaire dans nos centres commerciaux
avec plus ou moins de bonheur parce que
dans certains cas on a gagné et d'autres
pas la difficulté n'était pas tranché au
fond mais c'était très difficile pour
des salariés de faire la police
de gens
dans les magasins je trouve que ce droit
de police s'étaient pas cette obligation
de police n'était pas à nous de le faire
et ce faisant je ne prenais pas partie
et c'est et
c'est très intéressant ce qui se passe
parce que je n'ai pas du tout dit ce que
vous avez dit c'est sûr chez nous non à
laurence ferrari me demander si la loi
passe est-ce que vous l'appliquerait la
réponse est oui qu'est ce que vous
auriez dit si j'avais dit le contraire
il m'est arrivé quelquefois d'être un
peu fanfaron mais
j'ai dit oui
on applique la loi et elle me dit mais à
ce moment là il ya deux cas il ya les
gens que vous prendrez qu'est ce que
vous ferez des autres on les pendra pas
avait il s'appelle pas tous djokovic
mais on pourra pas hélas et qu'est-ce
que vous voulez que je dise ça on me
pose la question tous les jours que je
vais à la télévision donc moi je les
emmerde pas les gens je veux pas
emmerder les gens pas plus le boulanger
que des agriculteurs que les antilles
mais après la fachosphère s'est mis à me
à me chatouiller et à me caricaturer
j'ai compris que il avait besoin d'un
mouton noir on a hésité de savoir s'il
fallait répondre ou pas et puis voilà
quoi c'est ça devient ridicule quoi et
donc je vous assure je respecte les
libertés de tous je pense que le vrai
courage politique utt si c'est justifié
de faire le
le l'obligation vaccinale pour tout le
monde après je veux je veux pas que nos
salariés soit
les policiers de l'utilisation de
veille sanitaire ça va c'est
que je suis car et quand même alors
la baguette c'est un peu je vais
commencer par ace et
c'est important quand même il donne les
réseaux sociaux on regarde plus ce qui
est dit tout le monde réagit avant même
d'avoir lu alors celle qui a été le
summum c'est madame lambert alors je
viens pas la chercher là à travers vous
mais en la regardant l m'attribuer des
trucs qu'on n'a jamais dit alors d'abord
on n'a pas baissé le prix de la baguette
elle et c'est le prix moyen qui était
pratiqué sur ce pain-là premier prix
dans les centres leclerc c'était la
campagne d'intermarché l'année dernière
cependant l'intérêt de leur dire dans
l'immédiat c'était le cas et c'est dans
le ck thériault la baguette premier prix
pain blanc dans les centres leclerc qu
elles étaient entre 0 22 et 0 32 il
fallait faire une publicité nationale on
un ami on l'a mis à 0,29 première vent
ensuite j'ai pas été chercher les
boulangers la publicité n'allez pas
chercher les boulangers et en plus
gonfler elle dit que ça s'oppose à la
revalorisation du prix du blé mais on se
les est enquis l eos dans le prix en
question on les a acceptées deux fois
les hausses de prix des céréales donc
aujourd'hui moi ce qui m'étonne ce qui
m'étonne ouais ouais bah après vous
aimez vous aimez pas on vend aussi de la
bad on va aussi de la baguette de
tradition dans tous les hypers de france
on vend
mais on en vend des millions
non non dans les 18 millions de clients
de carrefour a à peu près le même nombre
de clients auchan un peu moins mais on
vend des gammes et c'est pas parce que
vous voyez on fait des foires aux vins
la foire aux vins aujourd'hui le vin
moyens c'est cet euro et pourtant tout
le monde voit les grands crus au tour
s'il vous plaît moi ce que ça m'a
impressionné c'est d'abord la réactivité
la classe politique comme ça c'est pas
de pas de coup de téléphone rien c'est
dégueulasse c'est pas bien et où il se
renseigne même pas car la fin de ce mois
et puis le 2 donc c'est un moment de
notre époque où il faut savoir que les
jambes sont un petit peu dingue quand
même ça ça réagit vite et le 2 la
deuxième chose enfin notre stratégie
elle est visible depuis plusieurs mois
face à la re retour de l'inflation c'est
de rassurer nos consommateurs sur des
produits qu'on appelle des marqueurs
dont ils connaissent le prix et donc que
dont nous avons décidé de bloquer ces
prix parce que par ailleurs tout le mur
du fond de rayon a changé voilà et donc
moi je suis fier de ça moi mon électorat
mon elector vous avez tous vos électeurs
moi mon électorat cc 18 millions de
personnes qui sont chez moi et qui vient
de faire leurs courses chez moi et ac et
auprès duquel je suis redevable
redevables d'augmenter le prix des
produits agricoles français à cause de
la loi et parce que c'est bien je vais
dire mais après faut me laisser ne pas
faire paniquer landerneau quoi merci
michel edouard evelyne renault
garabédian en visioconférence ensuite ça
sera bernard but
merci n'entonne monsieur leclerc
lannoy climat et résilience a prévu un
affichage environnemental obligatoire
faut les produits textiles d'aliments
ainsi que pour les publicités
correspondante cette obligation
interviendra après une période
d'expérimentation durée maximale de 5
ans qui débute le 22 janvier proche du
22 février prochain vol en décembre
dernier
votre enseigne a annoncé essayé
différentes méthodes pour mesurer
l'empreinte environnementale
s'agit d'un chantier d'ampleur
leclerc étant le premier vendeur de
vêtements en france avec 6 9% de part de
marché en volume est ce que vous nous
préciser quelles sont les méthodes
expérimentées pour calculer l'empreinte
environnementale
nouveau production ainsi que le
calendrier
de l'évaluation que vous avez prévu
merci votre immense merci evelyne pour
le pour le détail on vous transmettre à
une note si vous voulez bien parce que
c'est pas forcément mon sujet
sur lequel je suis le plus compétent
mais
sur this aille à notre marque puisque
nous avons la maîtrise des cahiers des
charges nous travaillons sur
l'information sur la localisation sainte
où toutes les informations que vous avez
souhaité on va essayer de la mettre en
place toutes les cases des
problématiques sont cochées
le timing je peux vous en raconter un
mais je peux vous envoyer en 2030 mais
on va le construire alors comment on dit
déjà en marchant
mais on va dans le sens que que sur
lequel vous avez travaillé madame ouais
c'est bien on note qu on aura un petit
peu d'informations supplémentaires
bernard puis ensuite pierre louault vous
êtes très nombreux donc merci présidente
je vais être très rapide puisque ma
question a été traitée c'était la même
que d'entre eux les héros de regarder
dia donc merci merci bernard formidable
ça me fait sauter aussi la réponse
pierre roux ensuite michel bonnus
je leur parle un peu de la baguette tout
simplement la crise a aussi démontré que
pendant cette crise les français manque
de lien social
la boulangerie reste un des liens
privilégiés y compris dans les villes
surtout les étudiants vont acheter leur
sandwich ou un chien certain nombre de
choses
je trouve dommage je suis un client
leclerc et pendant un certain temps je
mets leclerc à l'index je vais au super
u et non plus au leclerc la cause de la
baguette
je trouve dommage vous qui êtes un homme
de terrain de ne pas prendre plus
d'attention au lien social si vous
vouliez faire gagner du pouvoir d'achat
vos clients
réduisez de moitié vos marges sur les
viandes transformées tels que le pâté et
là vraiment vos clients auraient
retrouvé des pouvoirs d'achat
trop de pattani trop de pain quand même
vous voyez vous répondez en politique
mais pas en tant que consommateur si je
puis me permettre mais non parce que si
vous étiez consommateurs dans un centre
leclerc vous auriez déjà vu cette
baguette est en fait c'est le fait que
tout d'un coup quelqu'un vous met
l'accent dessus et tout d'un coup
emotionnellement parce qu'il ya une
polémique avec les boulangers mais les
boulangers il n'y avait pas de polémique
avait que vous voyez est donc après il
faut savoir que en cette période
pré-électorale et puis on a aussi des
élections corporatiste enfin et c'est
dans les chambres de commerce et où tout
le monde fait son petit chou gras de
cette polémique donc moi ça ça me fait
du mal parce que la boulangère de mon
visage de mon village je l'adorent pour
ne pas dire plus
mais mais je trouve que notre mission
notre mission sociale mais non notre
mission sociale c'est les premiers
clients de les premiers clients de nos
magasins sont souvent les agriculteurs
et je vais rajouter à une information
sur la mayenne
30% de variations du prix du blé ne fait
que une variation qu'un impact de 1
centime sur la bâillonne
[Musique]
30% un centime donc qu'on arrête de
faire tout ce cinéma en liant le prix de
vente à la rémunération des agriculteurs
j'ajouterai que s'il ya des agriculteurs
à défendre aujourd'hui je les verrais
plutôt du côté porcin ou dans la
production porcine le court aujourd'hui
est compliqué hiram 1,24 par là c'est
compliqué même si vous rajoutez 0,16 de
qualification et c'est ça c'est un vrai
sujet un sujet de groupe un sujet
interprofessionnelle et puis entre nous
enfin j'aimerais bien que vous le
vérifier mais je pense pas que les
céréaliers dans l'histoire il est
beaucoup et est à plaindre je ne pense
pas qu'ils ont eu leurs coûts de
production
on parle des galipes 2 je pense pas que
l'augmentation des prix du blé vient de
égalise 2 on est bien d'accord c'est pas
les augmentations des coûts de
production des céréaliers et à ma
connaissance ils sont parmi les premiers
bénéficiaires des subventions
européennes
donc je vais pas dire du mal des
céréaliers mais je trouve que c'est pas
bien d'opposer les céréaliers au
consommateur ou de culpabiliser les
consommateurs
ok j'accepte
j'accepte le côté pagnol de
bonnes francilienne salle edouard
leclerc je vous dirais que ce n'est pas
bien de poser les céréaliers aux autres
agriculteurs michel bonnus sans suite
guylaine martel
merci merci présidente et le droit de
police n'est pas évident n'est évident
pour personne monsieur le président le
droit de police seront pas évident pour
personne surtout pas sûr non simplement
avec mes collaborateurs nous avons
téléphoné aux producteurs locaux de mon
département le var pour pour travailler
qui travaillent avec vous
je nous avons de bons retours non
seulement ils sont considérés et les
personnes qui sont entrées en sont venus
aux mains nues leurs produits au juste
prix donc il faut être jeune à faire
passer plus de 18 pour le téléphone on a
eu 18 fournisseurs qui nous ont dit que
maintenant avec les chefs de rayon et
les directeurs sais pas évidemment par
contre je soulèverai dans le cadre dans
le cas d'alliances locales dans le
département du var depuis deux ans et
nous avons créé un souk al et ma
question est la suivante est ce que est
ce que vous serez les scansions et le
bien mis en valeur et est-ce qu'elle va
revenir très bien compris si on me l'a
proposé comptez vous impulsez la mise en
place et le maintien des annonces
locales qui vont êtres qui ont été
dissoutes notamment dans le var voilà
bah oui
c'est ma question on va les vallées en
tous les cas entre lesquels et 18 18
entreprises qui travaillent avec entre
parenthèses leclerc de hyères qui est
quelqu'un d'important
je n'ai pas une qui m'a dit qui m'a dit
du mal et au contraire on travaille mais
c'est positif je milite beaucoup pour le
développement des alliances locales si
vous avez besoin de relais si vous
entendez des choses après je vous cache
pas que je peux le faire le médiateur
oui nous ferons parce qu'ils m'ont
rassuré
merci michel ghislaine pantel pardon et
ensuite franck montaugé merci à la
présidence puis je vais faire comme
bernard bima question a été posée donc
j'ai attendu des réponses de monsieur
leclerc donc je crois sur quoi elle peut
garder la brigade et meudon commerci bon
c'était sûr et galim de mercy ghislaine
franck montaugé donc et ensuite patrick
chaize oui j'avais une question
communauto collègues qui a été posé par
la lorraine diplôme et daniel rémy en
particulier donc je reviens pas dessus
je salue quand même là la conversion de
laurent duplomb impro un progressisme à
un progressisme que je souhaite durable
et si effectivement il devait durer nous
on est ouverte et on peut peut-être
envisager de t'intégrer voilà
je crains que laurent duclos préfèrent
les blondes ou brunes mais fabre c'est
un autre sujet d'accord
trêve de plaisanterie monsieur monsieur
leclerc
merci pour votre exposé vous et vos
réponses je voudrais revenir sur le
marché de l'électricité auquel vous êtes
intéressé que vous avez évoquées dont
vous êtes donc vous êtes sorti
on y revient la voilà donc je je je vais
y venir moi aussi je ne pense pas qu'on
fiche à dire comme on vous l'avait
exprimé que ça n'a rien coûté à l'état
je pense que cette affaire-là va coûter
très cher à l'état pas spécifiquement
votre sortie du marché de manière
générale et un parti
ça vous concerne la main je pense pas
qu'on puisse se désengager de cette
affaire là comme ça au delà au-delà de
cette de cette remarque
je vous êtes un fin analyste des marchés
de la consommation
j'aurais aimé vous vous entendre sur le
l'analyse le regard que vous portez sur
le fonctionnement du marché de
l'électricité des marchés de
l'électricité
qui dysfonctionne c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire à l'heure actuelle voilà
quelle quelle est votre analyse
de cela et aurez vous des propositions à
faire
dans l'intérêt du consommateur est
également de la souveraineté
énergétique nationale je vous remercie
franck
techniquement c'est un marché que qu'on
a commencé à regarder il ya il y a
d'abord
dans les carburants on est devenu le
deuxième distributeur de carburants en
france on approvisionne même système u
leclerc on a une société commune la ratp
on est un gros opérateur sur le marché
et c'était mon premier combat quand je
suis rentré dans les centres leclerc
puisque je vous rappelle que
ma première
le manière dont j'ai été connu c'est
leclerc contre l'état français pour
faire sauter les lattes l'interdiction
de rabais sur les carburants à la cour
de justice européenne
après
on s'est intéressé au marché de des
économies d'énergie par le système des
pénalités on est aussi et de rachat de
pénalités on est un des plus gros
acheteurs de certificats d'énergie donc
on s'intéresse à l'ensemble du marché
écologique et énergies de demain
sur l'électricité franchement je voulais
et nous voulions c'est un centre leclerc
de nantes qui prenait le dossier en main
on voulait distribuer de l'électricité
verte et pas simplement du faussement
vert et on s'est rendu compte que
l'électricité verte que l'électricité
le prix ne pouvait pas être décoré les
de l'ensemble du marché de l'électricité
ce a achevé de me convaincre que pour le
moment il fallait faire plus de
géopolitique que de macroéconomie et
et tant qu'on n'a pas au niveau européen
déterminer les règles de fonctionnement
et de fixation de prix on peut pas
lancer des opérateurs privés alternatif
ça n'a pas de sens enfin c'est vrai ça
va coûter 18 milliards
alors peut-être que ça fera aussi un
indice de prix est un peu moindre avant
les élections mais c'est c'est clair
c'est ce que disait monsieur robin dans
les pages saumon du figaro
hier
nous avec nos techniciens on a vraiment
des gens des collaborateurs excellent
qui viennent de eni qui viennent en fait
on sait pas faire en l'absence de règles
sur un marché et donc on n'est plus dans
l'économie de marché on n'est pas non
plus dans une économie interventionniste
clair on est dans un jeu géopolitique
non maîtrisée et c'est pour ça que les
questions de si ce n'est de
souverainisme sais c'est des questions
qu'on discute à l'iris aussi fait c'est
ça sert à rien de prêt temps d'ouvrir un
marché si on ne maîtrise pas ni un
morceau d'os ni un morceau de demande
quoi vous êtes pour une réforme du
marché de l'électricité
wen qui ne pas être le relais
merci beaucoup patrick chaize ensuite
daniel salmon mais la présidente merci
monsieur leclerc donc merci pour vos
propos vous allez
très très large dans votre présentation
et notamment vous avez des chiffres en
disant finalement nos candidats aux
élections présidentielles a été choisi
par une centaine de milles de personnes
que joue finalement c'était 18 millions
se compare pas 18 millions de noms mais
comme quand même 18 millions de
personnes qui vous parlais qu'est-ce qui
vous disent
aux dires de deuxième deuxième petite
question qui revient sur justement vos
ventes à prix coûtant donc le carburant
le pain donc vous augmentez la scène de
direction là et pourtant donc une
progression est là les résultats sont
aussi là où vous êtes en bonne santé
financière c'est quoi votre secret
alors
je vais vous donner ses objectifs après
les situations dans lequel sont le
ce sont les personnes sur cette histoire
de la baguette comme avance sur
l'histoire des carburants quand on lui
disait on il baisse de 3 chantilly il
était déjà un casier à prix coûtant
sur tous les indicateurs que nous avons
de réaction de la clientèle nous n'avons
que du positif même sur mes réseaux
sociaux je montrais tout à l'heure à
alexandre sur un j'ai à peu près un
million d'abonnés partage et linkedin je
pense qu'on peut les croiser c'est un
million d'abonnés
consolidé spc
il n'y a que du positif
alors qu'autour de moi à la télévision
les corporations des élus des ministres
nous disent que c'est pas bien c'est là
où je me dis je suis pas idiot je veux
pas faire du populisme
voyez mais je me dis qu'il ya une
déconnexion entre elles et les gens
savent pas le prix les choses quoi les
gens qui passent savent pas le prix des
choses et en fait aujourd'hui les
premiers prix dans les hypermarchés
sont revenus à la lumière de la crise
j'aurais peut-être dû insister là-dessus
tout à l'heure dans mon exposé et donc
les pattes premier prix
les les produits d'entretien mais toute
façon vous avez vu l'année dernière le
président de la république a proposé aux
proust pour les étudiants un menu à 1
euro nous nous avons fait ça aussi une
publicité sur les menus à 1 euro ça vous
dit ça vous dit le prix des intrants ça
vous dit le prix auquel les gens
achètent les intrants quand
on parle de kits hygiène on a investi
sur des kids personne n'en parle pas les
hommes en plus a pas trop en parler mais
d'équipement strubel des kits d'hygiène
pour les femmes ben
c'est tout le monde parle des marques et
tout ça mais dans les foyers français
outre un machisme primaire des
complications dues pour une adolescente
dans une famille qui n'est pas si libre
que ça je vous rendez compte que devant
la de 0,25 un truc qui peut être vendu 6
euros en pharmacie que ça le fait c'est
pas pour taper sur les femmes c'est
juste ça donc aujourd'hui notre plus les
français sont très sensibles aux prix
leur préoccupation essentielle c'est le
pouvoir d'achat la santé c haque bien
sûr mais ils le vivent qui c'est sûr
jouer à la télé tous les soirs alors que
lol le pouvoir d'achat c'est vraiment la
préoccupation des français et ils
comptent sur nous mais vous prendrez le
train avec moi vous vous seriez étonnés
d'antan on ne me parle que de ça et donc
et est donc moi je dois y répondre je
dois y répondre parce que ne serait ce
que pour protéger d'abord les cent
quarante mille salariés qui travaillent
sous une autre enseigne ensuite regarder
quels sont les enseignes de distribution
aujourd'hui qui marche en france c'est
leclerc intermarché lidl
10 alors tout ce discours qui nous dit
il faudra augmenter les prix qu'ils
aillent monter leur commerce et qu'ils
nous montrent comment ils font vous
voyez en fait moi je pense qu'on peut
apporter ça on peut apporter cette
revalorisation du monde agricole à
travers des enseignes où les gens ont
confiance justement que ces hausses de
prix sont argumentées et puis il faut le
faire avec le tempo du pouvoir d'achat
des gens saas etc c'est vraiment
essentiel et ça tout à l'heure je me
rappellerai changer une proposition fin
juin bon en fait vous m'avez demandé
tout à leurs informations inflation
durable ou pas durable alors c'est sûr
qu'il ya une inflation pas durable post
co vide qui tenait compte de la
perturbation des circuits des transports
pendant la période du colis celle là
elle montre je suis plus comment ils
disent à la bce la va arriver sur un
un palier et elle va descendre je ne
sais pas jusqu'où elle va descendre
mais toute la nouvelle économie
toute la nouvelle économie
transition énergétique transition
écologique transition alimentaire où on
dit transition mais nouveaux modèles
tout ça ça va coûter plus cher tout va
coûter plus cher pour trois raisons la
première c'est que le fait qu'on y aille
fait que on tire un trait sur nos
anciennes usines de montage sur nos
anciennes fusil sur nos anciennes
pratiques elles n'ont pas fini d'être
amorti donc c'est un coup
en plus moi en usine de montage en usine
de montage de flins ou deux il faut
aussi la recycler ses dix ans de coups
d'accords le marché n'est pas forcée du
recyclage n'est pas forcément
rémunérateur donc déjà la fin avant
terme de l'ancienne économie fait que on
a un coût durable durable pour longtemps
attali 10 et décennale et
ça fait sens je pense et de l'autre côté
la nouvelle économie n'a pas encore son
marché parce qu'on sait pas la
réactivité des consommateurs sur des
niveaux de prix très élevé or on
achètera tout cela
apple 15 enfin vous voyez ce que je veux
dire l'iphone machin etc mais dans nos
18 millions de clients là qui ont un
salaire médian de leurs de 1850 1860
euros
je je je crois que il n'y aura pas le
marché de la nouvelle économie avant dix
ans
alors autant les chinois les indiens
ont été posées que ce faire la
géopolitique ils ont les capacités un
peu autorités savent le féminisme de fer
amortir très vite une nouvelle voiture
un nouveau train un nouveau système
d'équipement
autant sur le seul marché français on va
pas trouver
capacité à amortir très vite la voiture
électrique
et tous les nouveaux équipements à
hydrogène et c'est donc vous je pense
qu'on rentre dans un système d'
inflation durable je ne veux pas jouer
les cassandre en plus nous appelons à
rentrer dans ce nouveau système mais
voilà le rôle de l'état et c'est ce que
nous avons écrit tous les deux dans dans
le petit livre qui s'appelait
essentielles de la république l'état est
de retour l'état accompagnateur est de
retour ça va coûter des sous puisqu'à
défaut de trouver des clients prêts à
payer ça va coûter des sous mais
j'insiste nos distributeurs dans ce rôle
là on va être des passeurs mais on ne
sera pas capable
et je ne le voudrais pas mais on sera
pas capable de de multiplier les prix
par
2 5 % par an c'est pas faisable regardez
la difficulté de l'économie américaine
aujourd'hui à 6%
et nos les salaires même si vous mettez
des primes même si vous mettez des
chèques
pour le moment c'est un moindre mal
d'accord c'est et c'est déjà bien qu'ils
aient quelque chose on peut critiquer la
forme c'est je ne sais pas comment c'est
financé comme on le rattrapera après
mais sur le coup
il ya une intention de l'état protecteur
qui accompagne et
mais c'est pas à la hauteur de ces deux
enjeux alors vous vous avez discuté du
100 euros du chèque 100 euros pour la
hausse de l'électricité
mais c'est tout l'alimentaire et tout ce
qu'on vend dans un hypermarché qui va
augmenter du même montant s'il vous
plaît vous avez droit de nous critiquer
et je prendrai des leçons dans vos
critiques mais mais je pense que mon
métier ma mission aujourd'hui c'est de
faire en sorte que l'état n'est pas
affaire de chèques pour chaque secteur
et que à travers une politique de prix
plus plus plus consumériste les
distributeurs limite la casse et c'est
quoi votre proposition
vous disiez vous voulez faire une
proposition déjà je pense qu'il faut
rétablir des politiques de concurrence
et de troncs tous nos discussions depuis
3 4 ans sur égalise on est en train de
discuter entre nous on dit qu'une
entente fait par des privés pour que
l'état ne crée pas des prix minimum ou
voilà deux 2015 on discute de ça
franchement très bien 45 ans de métier
j'ai jamais vu pendant ce temps là tout
le secteur sélectif
les nike les adidas les téléphones
portables sont tous vendus au même prix
ça c'est inquiète personnes par
l'autorité de la concurrence et tout ça
on pourrait peut-être pour le coup donné
un coup de main aux producteurs de porcs
avec chopin à 2 ans de 2 ans avec
obligation
écologique derrière on pourrait
peut-être supprimé du coup les nos
histoires de nitrates en bretagne une
entente sur trois ans pour pour
qu'ils s'investissent dans ce système là
enfin franchement pourquoi est-ce
qu'elles seraient moins
éligibles intellectuellement
et politiquement et qu'on laisse se
faire tout le secteur du luxe au même
prix quoi ce jeu je comprends pas il
nous faut une politique de concurrence
mais quand ça marche pas et quand le
marché ne marche pas comme l'électricité
aux autres ont fait de la régulation
très bien puisque vous parler d'écologie
je vais donner la parole à daniel salmon
vous êtes encore 11 à poser des
questions donc voilà daniel seulement
après la journée
oui mes fans ou parce qu'on a une
proposition de loi derrière et il est
président monsieur leclerc vous venez
pas de parler des deux ports
vous croyez comme beaucoup d'entre nous
à la valeur travail et aujourd'hui les
paysans qui travaillent 15 heures par
jour et qui n'arrivent pas à vivre
dignement d' de ce travail 56 % des
exploitations ont disparu des
exploitations agricoles ont disparu en
25 ans est ce que vous pensez pas que
vous avez une part de responsabilité
dans ce désespoir du monde agricole vous
parliez également de souveraineté notre
balance commerciale n'est pas aux yeux
on ne peut pas dire
qu est ce que vous pensez des traités de
libre échange qui aujourd'hui vous
parler de concurrence met en concurrence
les tous les producteurs tous les
travailleurs du monde entier tant que
j'aimerais bien avoir votre vision là
dessus et dernière petite question qui
n'en est pas une petite d'ailleurs nous
savons que
les défis qui sont devant nous les défis
climatiques en particulier nous oblige
nous obligerait un politique de
frugalité et de sobriété
est-ce que comment voyez-vous
la grande distribution et le groupe
leclerc entrer dans une politique de
plus de frugalité et de sobriété et
sortir d'une certaine forme de
consumérisme qui nous a amenés là où
nous sommes aujourd'hui merci merci
daniel c'est déjà trois questions
[Rires]
nous achetons notre port à 97% français
nous l'achetons à plérin quand tout le
monde a au marché de cotation quand
toutes les autres se sont barrés et nous
sommes celui qui est le cas est celui
qui achète le plus cher à plérin
comment
est ce mal
et donc chers compatriotes nous nous
nous donc nous sommes en discussions
aujourd'hui avec nos outils de
production avec kerméné on vient de
signer un accord avec les aop pour la
castration des cochons on a face au
bien-être animal
le dialogue est bon mais c'est vrai que
le cours ne paye pas donc la discussion
qui peut pas être public là
mais qui rassemble les hommes c'est
comment on peut
comment on peut faire monter le cours
après excusez moi c'est moi qui suis
embêté après parce que ouais vous voyez
il ya une volonté de bien faire et sur
la transition alors la sobriété oui oui
tu es de libre-échange sobriété si vous
faites alors
il ya sobriété frugalité
d'abord ça peut pas être une frugalité
et sobriété imposé
on n'est pas en chine on n'est pas
en russie c'est pas moi qui vais vous
dire comment nous aller
combien d'enfants vous allez faire
qu'est ce que vous allez faire etc enfin
c'est pas encore moins à un privé quoi
donc oui
la consommation est arrivé il ya eu trop
de gaspillage il ya eu trop de
d'atteinte il faut la consommation il
faut que la chine devienne au sens
étymologique plus conservatrice vous
voyez c'est un beau cul connoté
politiquement mais il faut qu'on
conserve
on a fait fructifier mais on a beaucoup
on a beaucoup gaspillé
et c'est pas simplement les
comportements individuels
ccc le mode de consommation on peut on
peut évoquer sa
aujourd'hui par exemple nous nous
travaillons beaucoup sur l'économie
circulaire et nous travaillons beaucoup
sur la récupération
leclerc a lancé un concept d'occasion
qui marche bien on en a une quarantaine
soixantaine oui système u s'y est mis
aussi
il y avait le bon coin quoi avant aussi
c'est des choses qui nous amène à
regarder la du la durée le prolongement
de la durée de vie des produits est ce
son est derrière des habitudes de
consommation
le seul truc que
que je vois fac est compliqué c'est que
dans la proche de la nouvelle économie
par les voitures là on sait pas quel est
le modèle qu'on pourrait faire durer
puisque vous voyez on est un mélange
aujourd'hui d'hybrides on parle
d'hydrogène on part on voit bien la
limitation on va prendre - la voiture
pour aller en ville on va prendre plus
de transport collectif mais il n'est pas
sûr que le modèle sont encore économe de
ses intrants
mais je partage
7,7 ce besoin de consommer moins ce
qu'on n'a pas à consommer quoi ouais
je suis pas sûr d'avoir la réponse
c'est vous le faiseur de ça
[Musique]